I'm here with Steve the owner sprinkler
where how he's about to tell us how we
run wire to our sprinkler systems
[Music]
what kind of why are we running today
Steve where we're gonna be running
direct burial irrigation wire today it's
16 gauge wire and it's made for direct
burials so we do not have to worry about
running conduit all the way back to the
controller we can just run the wire in
the ground in the same trenches as the
pipe and we'll just tuck the wire up
underneath the pipe just to protect it
from any shovels in the future or
anything like that the best we can we'll
tuck it up underneath but again we don't
have to worry about running conduit
because we are using wire that's that's
designed for direct burial out here in
the yard we're gonna be running our wire
from the controller in this situation
it's in the backyard in the garage we're
gonna be coming from that controller
around the back of the property down the
side of the house and then across the
front over here to our furthest bowels
away from the controller so starting
here we need to make sure that we've got
a red wire or a hot wire for each valve
in this case we've got three valves so
we're gonna have three red wires but you
only need one common that's it
not ten yes can you change yeah daisy
chain we would normally run the wire
straight from these valves all the way
back to the controller and tucking the
wire underneath the pipe to protect it
but we got to be careful I always advise
people walk the property back to the
controller and make sure you're not
going to cross any obstacles that would
prevent you from running the wire in
this case as as we've been discussing
here and you can see we've got a
sidewalk to deal with
we've gone under it earlier with a piece
of conduit so that we prepared ourselves
to go into this with wire so instead of
starting here and rolling our rolls back
we're gonna start here bring the wire
underneath in the conduit over to the
valves hook up the valves and finish
running the wire around the side of the
house to the backyard after we've done
these we'll start over here on these
valves we'll run our two red wires all
the way back to the controller again
and then we'll finish up with our valves
that are in the backyard and do the same
thing all right now I've pulled the wire
down to the valve I'm gonna tuck it in
underneath the pipe and I'm gonna leave
about two and a half feet of coil
because you want to have about two and a
half extra feet to coil up for to
protect for surges
all right so this right here is a little
coil and we're gonna make one on the
rest of these wires now what this does
is as it adds a little bit of a extra
protection against power surges so we're
gonna take a little pipe like this
unwrap our cabling we're gonna go ahead
and leave some slack right there we're
gonna wrap it around right down here
like this boom coil then you do that to
all of them just took a little extra
down start your
[Music]
to see how we're just jump
so he goes from this one to that one we
have our control
[Music]
and don't forget your waterproof wire
nuts
[Music]
take the white wire only and I'm gonna
pull white wire I need you to let the
roll or white wire
[Music]
now in order to protect your wires from
damage you're gonna want to run it
through some PVC conduit from where it
comes out of the ground all the way to
your smart control
[Music]
and you don't good there's no water
alright now we got all the wires running
to our controller we have our rain
sensor wire right here we're gonna hook
that up we got our common wire we're
gonna hook that up as well
we're gonna turn the power onto this
thing and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna strip the red wires one by
one and we're gonna touch them to a
powered terminal what that's gonna do is
gonna start to isolate which wire goes
to which zone because we don't know
which wire goes to which is own at this
point so if we turn on terminal number
one and start touching a wire to it what
what's gonna happen is it's gonna turn
on one of the zones in our yard let's
just say that turns on number seven we
count one two three four five six seven
connect it to number seven over here and
go on down the line until we know which
wire goes to which zone and then we
connect it to that corresponding zone
let's get started
okay that's number that's the flower bed
so that
number six
[Music]
remember sprinkler warehouse has
everything for your irrigation needs so
your trees lawn gardens and flower beds
are lush and beautiful and if you have
any questions about irrigation chat with
one of our superb customer service
agents on sprinkler warehouse.com
they really know their stuff and they
will get you squared away subscribe to
our YouTube channel for helpful tips
tutorials and general sprinkler
destruction i'm adrian sanchez your
sprinkler warehouse pro I'll see you
later irrigator